hot breath tobias says hey beth
how did you get into comedy
well i was born the youngest of three
girls
and i my sisters were
you know i guess it's all cheesy
sounding but it's like you know my
sisters were so loving and doted on me i
was
i wasn't you know tormented by my older
siblings
i was really made the sort of center of
attention in a lot of ways
and i always wanted to keep up with them
so i was trying to
be probably intellectually ahead of
where i was i think that's the benefit
of being the youngest
is you kind of develop quicker um
intellectually because you're trying to
keep up with
the kids around you which are your
siblings so
and i love making them laugh so i mean
those are my origin
my origin story i mean this much of it
but i guess stand up
i got into um by encouragement from my
my girlfriends in college i would kind
of come home either from school or work
or
whatever it was and make them laugh i
would just kind of you know stand in the
living room by
buy the tv as an alternate form of
entertainment and make them laugh and
i think for a while there i had another
friend in high school will
allen who had given me a jim gafkin
cd burned these were the burn cd days
and that was really my first
introduction to stand-up and
i loved jimmy's very talented but it's
not necessarily like i listened to that
and fell in love it was just sort of
like oh this is the thing
stand-up comedy is a thing where because
i didn't grow up like listening to it or
adoring it particularly um
and then dane cook happened and that was
when i was in college
and it was like
dane cook was incredible we loved him
you know you have to think about where
you are and what you love at the time
and dane was it so like you know on
the coats
and all those bits we were just like you
know memorizing laughing listening to in
the car
so that was the first time you felt like
that was like a comedy superstar
in my formative years or introduction to
stand up
so then it was almost intimidating for
me to start but
i went down to charleston south carolina
first boleto
my friends were in a band called bell
and they were playing and they
they were it's like i always had these
friends pushing me championing me being
like you're so funny you should use dana
and the transition from being funny for
your friends to and to stage on a
microphone
is probably obviously the biggest
scariest step and
not seamless so they just let me open
for them
and that meant me telling one of the
stories that i told them about my
childhood that made them laugh
on a stage in a bar but it was you know
breaking the seal it was terrifying
and i did it and it was exhilarating and
it was bad
i mean yeah i was it's probably the
equivalent of being like
hey honey you're like telling a little
kid to tell a joke and they're like okay
yeah so i think like that's how i
started stand up officially i suppose
was in charleston
and i same weekend we went and saw isaac
witty and amy schumer
and they were on tour with one other
comic i feel bad i can't remember his
name but
um you know honestly people say this
about me a lot i've gotten a few
mentions like i think netflix put out a
question like who's a stand-up comic
that made you
think you could do stand-up or want to
do stand-up and a lot of people are like
beth's telling and you're kind of like
is that a good thing or a bad thing
like if this kid can do it
um but i will say that about amy i
watched her in that festival and i was
like i can do this
so i think you know that also speaks to
representation i'm seeing
a woman on stage with these guys and i'm
like yeah yeah i can do that
and i was probably like i don't know how
old i was the time 20
or something like that